abend und willkommen zur zdf heute live
heute nachmittag mitten in der
innenstadt von würzburg
ein mann greift mit einem messer mehrere
menschen an es gibt tote und verletzte
die hintergründe der attacke
mitten in der stadt wie gesagt im moment
noch unklar
ein großteil des gebiets wurde am
nachmittag abgeriegelt der mutmaßliche
täter sei hieß es von seiten der polizei
überwältigt und festgenommen worden
die polizei habe dafür allerdings auch
schießen müssen ob der mann verletzt
wurde bzw auch wie schwer wurde zunächst
nicht gesagt wir sprechen über diese tat
mit einem kollegen von mir von der main
post in würzburg torsten schleicher ist
uns nämlich zugeschaltet schönen guten
abend herr schleicher wo sehen wir sie
da gerade und wo stehen sie und was ist
da im hintergrund bei ihnen zu
beobachten
ja ich befinde mich hier in der
theaterstraße in würzburg das ist die
straße die direkt zum tatort führt der
tatort liegt hinter uns wo man den
hintergrund dieses große gebäude sieht
der tatort ist der barbarossaplatz ein
sehr beliebter platz in der würzburger
innenstadt und gerade natürlich auch
jetzt in diesem wärmeren tagen auch am
abend stark frequentiert was weiß man
bislang zum hergang dieser tat also wir
wissen dass bei der polizei gegen 17 uhr
eine entsprechende meldung einging dass
es angriffe in der juliuspromenade das
ist die große straße die dann vom
barbarossaplatz weg führt gibt dass dort
ein mann in der fußgängerzone unterwegs
ist und auf menschen mit einem messer
einsticht nach allem was wir wissen gibt
es bisher drei tote und zehn verletzte
der mann konnte dann von der polizei
nach einem schusswaffengebrauch
bewältigt werden und festgenommen werden
und vorher hatten wie wir wissen
menschen die auf der juliuspromenade
unterwegs waren und den liegenden café
saßen auch versucht mit stühlen mit
allem was sie in die hand bekommen haben
den mann
weiteren taten zu ende sie sprachen auch
von von wahllosen angriffe und attacken
das klingt jetzt nicht nach einer
gezielten tat oder nach einer
beziehungstat oder dergleichen kann man
schon irgendwas über die hintergründe
sagen also über die hintergründe hat
sich die polizei moment noch sehr
bedeckt wie überhaupt das sehr lange
gedauert hat bis die medien hier in
würzburg informationen von der polizei
bekommen haben sagt zwei stunden
gedauert bis die ersten offiziellen
informationen über die hintergründe das
heißt die motive ist noch nichts bekannt
was man weiß dass es sich um einen
24-jährigen somalia anders der hier in
[Musik]
der innenminister ist auf dem weg das
meldet auch die deutsche presse agentur
der innenminister allerdings von bayern
joachim herrmann wie ist das zu
interpretieren hat dass irgendeine
besondere bedeutung wie schätzen sie das
ein
das hat er zweifellos eine besondere
bedeutung also würzburg ist für
gewöhnlich eine sehr ruhige und
friedliche stadt in der hermann ist
übrigens vor etwa einer halben stunde
bereits hier eingetroffen er hat sich an
der juliuspromenade über den tatort
informiert hat dass auch einmal
informationen aufgenommen und auch
informationen gegeben und ist danach
weiter zum presse lagezentrum gefahren
presse lagezentrum also wenn es so etwas
schon gibt dann wird vermutlich auch die
presse dann demnächst nochmal von
höchster stelle informiert werden gibt
es so eine art fahrplan können sie sagen
wie es heute abend seitens der behörden
weiter gehen wird oder soll also ist
dass der minister jetzt zu den patienten
unterwegs ist wird sich auch belegt und
wird weiter vor ort er wird noch weitere
informationen geben was wir auch noch
wissen was das die verletzten in
umliegende krankenhäuser auch in das
spital gebracht wurden und besorgt
werden wieder weitere ärgern heute abend
ist das weiß ich allerdings jetzt auch
nicht gut vielen dank erstmal für diese
informationen bisher hin ich bin gerade
so frei und lese auch noch mal ein paar
tweets vor die wir vorbereitet haben und
von
offizieller seite sozusagen markus söder
der ministerpräsident von bayern auf
twitter entsetzliche und schockierende
nachricht aus würzburg wir trauern mit
den opfern und deren familien wir bangen
und hoffen mit den verletzten dank an
die polizei für das rasche eingreifen
und auch cem özdemir ist auf twitter zu
lesen mit ja eigentlich nur der
feststellung dass der täter somalia ist
das haben wir gerade auch schon gehört
fakten statt spekulationen durch den
angriff eines 24-jährigen somalia kamen
drei menschen zu tode
weitere wurden zum teil schwer verletzt
dass ein statement der polizei
der in würzburg wohnende mann wurde
durch eine polizeikugel getroffen
befindet sich aber außer lebensgefahr
also auch da kann man dann zumindest
darauf hoffen dass ist dann weitere
erkenntnisse zum hintergrund dieser tat
geben wird torsten schleicher war das
für uns vor ort wir haben denke ich dass
besprochen was man momentan besprechen
kann oder fällt ihnen noch ein wichtiger
gesichtspunkt ein
ja man kann vielleicht sagen heute abend
hat ja eigentlich der christopher street
day beginnen sollen er hat auch gewonnen
allerdings ganz anders als erwartet
mit einer schweigeminute
oberbürgermeister christian schubert ja
auch sich vom geschehen überzeugt hat
bei dieser gelegenheit dann auch der
opfer gedacht und ja das hört sich viele
andere leute haben ganz anders
vorgestellt
letzte frage herr schleicher gibt es
irgendwelche anhaltspunkte dafür dass
weitere gefahr drohen könnte dass der
mann nicht alleine gehandelt hat
die polizei hat im ersten statement
gegen 19 uhr bereits gesagt dass es sich
um einen das bisher noch an der kette
nur einen täter gibt wurden jetzt auch
in gewahrsam ist dass keine weiteren
täter unterwegs sind und dass die
bevölkerung sicher ist nichtsdestotrotz
sind weite teile der innenstadt
abgesperrt
vielen dank für diese erste einschätzung
und schilderungen torsten schleicher
reporter von der main-post uns
zugeschaltet aus würzburg und wir
erhalten sie unter euch liebe zuschauer
natürlich auf dem laufenden was diesem
fall angeht alles weitere dann hier
entweder bei uns oder bei den kollegen
im tv im zweiten oder natürlich auch
online
vielen dank fürs interesse und biss den
ist schön amt sehen